c'est le dominique qui meurent proposait
un scénario c'était ce troisième film
qu'on fait ensemble et puis m'avait dit
que c'était pour faire injustement un
duo avec cadets on se connaissait comme
ça un petit peu je me suis dit faut
vraiment que ça me plaise parce que j'ai
vraiment envie de travailler avec ces
deux là
moi j'aime beaucoup franck je sais
qu'aucune fut beaucoup rire j'aime bien
ce spectacle j'aime bien sûr son énergie
son univers sa façon de jouer est en
fait on sait on s'est vraiment très bien
entendu mais qui sera sûrement oui
c'était une bonne idée de ne rencontrer
que c'était le bon scénario
il ya une vraie une vraie complicité on
a envie de faire un bon film ensemble et
c'est un tandem un vrai tandem de cinéma
et c'est très agréable
il ya deux solutions soit on en 86
souvenir de l'ancien enfin commencer
dans le film une scène devant un miroir
ou serveurs postes qu'ils ont 17 ans et
que quand on les voit ils ont
l'apparence de 17 ans c'est la première
fois que je les ai tourné tous les deux
dans le cadre et c'est devenu évident
instantanément le couple était là et il
avait trouvé ils ont trouvé leurs
marques en en dix minutes c'était fait
quoi il était dans la peau de leurs
personnages s'ils étaient les
personnages
ce qui m'amusait c'est d'envoyer deux
potes dans le passé et qui vont échanger
leur vie et qu'ils vont dire toi tu
prends la mienne je prends la tienne et
on va voir ce qui va arriver et qu'en
fin de compte on peut rien faire pense
que c'est très jubilatoire et pour les
acteurs et pour les spectateurs de se
replonger comme ça dans les années 80 tu
déshabille les rues tuner enlève maximum
de trucs parce que plus rien à avoir
avec les années 90 on a créé du mobilier
urbain on a ressorti des bus on n'a rien
installer des fontaines c'était marrant
ce monde se dire ah oui c'était comme ça
ah oui c'est vrai surtout quand on a
toujours notre physique de 2 50 ans
doucement un peu de respect blogueur
dépassez pas sûr que tu tapes histoire
coupez les lichens celle là elle est
très très bonnes c'est la très très très
bon c'est kelly dame